hey what's up guys my name is Jenna and
welcome to a vlog / update video I
haven't done a vlog in a while but some
I thought that I take this opportunity
to do it because i have finished
University for this year and I've got
like three months of holidays so I just
wanted to update with you guys with
what's happening and so that's our first
of all thank you for 20,000 subscribers
seriously I've never done a thank you
video before because every time that I
kind of want to do one I kind of just
put it off or I don't have anything
planned and then I'm like well okay I
didn't do one for 10,000 I'll I guess
I'll just I'll do one for 20,000 and
then then it could cook good because I'm
just like well you know that's that's
ages away I'll have enough time to plan
for that and everything but it comes off
really quickly and and I'm kind of
caught with my pants down and I've
absolutely nothing for you guys I'm
sorry but thank you for 20,000
subscribers okay honestly I really
appreciate that now on to more things so
are the game programming series right
episode 100 is going to come out soon I
know that I've kind of been delaying it
it's just because these last few weeks
of University have been really hectic
and and I've obviously had exams and
like the amount of work I've done this
like semester guys is just it's
ludicrous to say the least like I mean I
just handed in like a 230 page folio on
Wednesday this was the last thing I had
to do 230 pets like double-sided pages
and everything like this thick 230 pages
of just programming crap and and I have
to be honest with you guys like this
year wasn't hard at all like it's not
hard in the sense that my heart is hard
but I it's not hard because you know I'm
pretty confident programmer and I've
been doing this for years so and I like
the course that i'm doing is software
development um so it wasn't hard but the
amount of work is just ridiculous so and
the thing is a lot of is really boring
kind of work like a lot of its just like
drawing diagrams and so that it's I hate
that stuff so yeah it was quite quite
the but it's done now which is awesome
so now I can get back to making videos
for you guys which is which will be
awesome so I'm game programming series
that's the thing continuing I don't
really know what it's going to end ok
because it's one of those things that I
could keep doing is kind of like I like
comparing it telecom
minecraft let's play kind of serious
right it can literally go on forever
yeah like there's no end it's not like a
campaign and like Call of Duty or
whatever where there's like the last
mission you completed your done it's
like I could keep adding stuff to that
game indefinitely like obviously I'm
going to keep doing it when I like 60 or
something that'd be ridiculous but it's
going to kind of continue for quite a
while eventually though I really want to
want to wrap it up as soon as I can but
I episode of hundred should be coming
out probably next week maybe yeah yeah
definitely next but probably like
tomorrow the day after maybe um 3d game
programming I am bringing that series
back okay I have never and I will never
just stop making a series on my channel
okay never i will always finish them
okay and 3d game programming is coming
back this month in december okay i
guarantee you guys that okay 3d game
programming is coming back I know you
guys are really excited for that and you
guys went waiting for Rebecca's been
over a year since the last episode but
3d game programming will be coming back
this month okay so stop asking me about
that it's happening now that being said
I'm actually gonna bring in a new series
once I finished network chat programming
which should be in about two or so weeks
because there's something called like
like a few episodes left maybe like 5 to
10 I'm actually gonna make a new series
this is gonna be like a Java beginners
kind of series from scratch kind of
thing so in other words is this series
will teach you java now there is i'm
doing this apart from the well as
heavily request it is because that there
are a lot of i realize that there is a
lot of content that will teach you java
on the internet but it's just it's not
really it's not really up to my standard
i feel right like it's not how i learned
java rinse it's not really it's it's
just it's not the way that I would teach
it and I want to have an opportunity to
to teach it like the way that I would so
what I want to do is make a really
really high quality series not just for
you guys obviously before anyone out
there on the internet I must learn java
and it's gonna be really high quality
it's going to be like really high
production value like I'm like it's
going to be like one of those light it's
not gonna be like a live kind of
commentary which is what I do with all
my other videos right like the name of
charity imporant game programming
whatever all those series they just me
like just you know type in here and do
carrot and actually just doing it live
I'm actually just gonna and like I don't
cut the videos or anything and like but
with this of course that there is going
to be like cousin coming like there's
gonna be like diagrams and so it's going
to be like really high quality and it
should effectively teach you job of like
in like 50 episodes or whatever just
like and I honestly I honestly recommend
even if you guys do know Java I honestly
recommend everyone to watch that series
just because it will definitely teach
you things that you don't know and more
often than i'll probably just answer a
lot of the questions you guys might have
about how code is written and why it's
written so um that's happening i'm
probably going to start that mid to late
december possibly even early january
2014 depending on how things roll out
but that's a that's kind of that's kind
of deal all right now the other thing
that's coming back while it's happening
is I actually have a gaming channel ok
it's you do you should youtube com /b
mr. sure no the mr.turner so that's my
gaming channel right so that's coming
back I've actually I actually stopped
out for like a few months just because I
was well I barely had enough chat and
I've time to this channel but basically
I'm bringing it back because I have not
been playing games all semester at
University all right seriously I have I
don't even know what game people play
like these days like what games do you
guys play like seriously what is out
there right now like I don't know I just
picked up on call duty ghosts just
because like I know that I might come a
bit a bit of a for that but I don't care
like there's not in my opinion you know
there's no other kind of Arkady
fast-paced shooter in which I can just
you know jump in and just demolish
everyone you know battlefield certainly
not like that it's slow paced and well
you can't really just take on six guys
by yourself and win so um I mean that's
I'm ever picked that up but I have
literally I was thinking about this just
then I've literally have not played like
any games this semester what if I plot
what have I been played like I think I
occasionally hopped into like a lobby
about of either that about both
battlefield 3 and um black ops 2 but
like apart from that like I've literally
just have not been playing games and
that kills me i really like i really
like doing that guys honestly I think
sure you guys do as well so if you guys
do enjoy gaming
hop over to the link will be in the
description you to a conference after
the mr.turner which is my gaming channel
probably going to be post GTA 5 or 7
again that I was even playing but i'll
be posting to GTA 5 obviously call duty
and battlefield so battlefield 4
probably maybe battlefield 2 i've
actually started playing call of duty to
as well recently not modern warfare 2
just call duty to and really good game
so i might post a lot of that as well i
will post a lot of that so anyway go
ahead subscribe to that channel if you
guys are interested in gaming content
for me now um the other thing is ah you
guys should all follow me on twitter as
well ok because i sometimes live stream
and we should probably follow my twitch
channel as well but it's not great with
following i don't like the way that
followers work on that a but um twitter
back on for surf the channel is my
twitter link i live stream a lot well I
don't live from a lot but I do
occasionally live stream and I don't
always put up a video on this channel
being like guys and live streaming go
check at me out just because it's
sometimes if it's a half if i only have
like half an hour or like an hour of
something and I don't feel like it's
really that much of an important stream
I just won't put up a video and a lot of
people miss out on that on that
experience which is well you know not
great so in other words if you want to
miss out on anything that i do then
twitter back on for / the cherno will
enable you to stay up to date i've also
got a facebook page if you're if you
don't on the twitter account Facebook
page it's facebook.com for / the cherno
and both my large frame is officially 50
v 4 / channel everything's for / de jure
no except my youtube channel because
some chump took the churner i don't know
who you are but you should become falta
de jure no is taken so i have to settle
for the next best thing which is the
journal project but anyway point is ah
that's pretty much gonna wrap up this
update video guys so there's a lot in
store for you guys this summer i really
hope that you enjoyed that there are
other like one-off videos and miniseries
that i might do for example like i don't
want to give away too much but like i
think i might do a bit of a podcast with
just random game developers out there
like indie game developers out there i'm
probably probably gonna look into that I
reckon that would be a lot of fun so
just like an hour of me talking with
like
2223 developers or something who have
actually made games and published them
and just you know just to give you guys
a bit of a perspective as well I'm what
happens in for me as well and for them
so that you guys can find out about a
lot of great games that are out there
and so like that anyway if you enjoy
this video please the like button really
not necessary but i'll see you guys next
time goodbye